well dr amish adoljo joins us for more
on the coronavirus he's a senior scholar
at the johns hopkins center for health
security
and he's in pittsburgh dr adalja good
morning
hi thanks for having me so you're an
expert on infectious diseases also
pandemic preparedness how do we get this
under control as you see
all of these rising cases and
hospitalizations
right now we have a pandemic that is
completely out of control
and the reason it's out of control is we
still don't have the public health
infrastructure to test
trace and isolate and without that
people can't know their status they go
about their lives and they infect other
people
you saw that long line at dodger stadium
that you showed we can't have testing
lines like that we have to be able to
test ourselves
almost on a daily basis maybe even at
home we brush our teeth test ourselves
and know what we can do that day we
can't do in november in the united
states what taiwan south korea could do
in march
so this really is is the reason why
we're we're seeing these surges and then
you have pandemic fatigue
on top of that so it's really a
conglomeration of activities but it's
still
we can't do the basics in public health
in this country doctor how worried are
you
right now about thanksgiving and the
pandemic
it's almost inevitable that we're going
to see increasing cases after
thanksgiving many people are traveling
i've seen pictures of crowded airports
most people are not modifying their
their arrangements
so this is going to be a place where
people are going to let their guards
down and we're going to see transmission
the epidemiology is changing we're not
seeing people get infected so much in
restaurants anymore
they're getting infected around their
own dining table so this is something
we really have to help people understand
that there is
risk there and that you cannot let your
guard down and you have to take some
common sense precautions
even in your own home when you're
inviting people from other households
there
earlier this week we saw in new york
city the largest school district in the
country
shut down in-person learning and you
wrote in an op-ed in the washington post
that this was the wrong move you were
not alone
in this belief what do you think school
districts should do going forward
it's a very difficult situation because
paradoxically children tend to be spared
and they don't necessarily
accelerate the transmission of this
infection the way they do for example
with influenza
and the data that we're seeing is that
people when they're in school
when when they're in the classroom
that's not driving infections it's very
very low
so i do think the priority has to be the
default has to be keeping schools open
and that's what europe is doing
they may shut other things down but they
keep schools going i think we have to
to put more priority on education in
this country than we have
amos you spoke to business insider
regarding both pfizer
and mcderner's vaccine saying that they
are
very similar the key will be
distribution
distribution distribution and i'm
curious to know
what are some of the challenges around
distribution in both of these cases
when it comes to the pfizer vaccine it's
something that requires
storage at a very cold temperature minus
70 centigrade that's not easy to do
and that's going to make it much harder
to get that into the arms of americans
so
we have to really think about how we're
going to turn this vaccine into a
vaccination and it's going to require a
lot of planning
in all 50 states to make sure that
people have access to this and that's
something we're
already starting to do but it's going to
have to accelerate very rapidly because
it's going to be one of the biggest
public health challenges
the modern vaccine doesn't require
storage but it's still
a big endeavor to try and mobilize that
much vaccine
that quickly remember these are two dose
vaccines so that's not
that's like 600 million doses so this is
something we've never done before
and we really have to make sure we get
it right there's going to be hiccups but
until we get the vaccine into people's
arms we're going to continue to still be
in this pandemic limbo but aren't there
also concerns into as to who
the vaccine will get to some of the
rural
and urban communities may not have the
access that's necessary
this is going to be a major issue to
make to to ensure that it's equitably
distributed
that all parts of this country get it
there's going to be priority groups that
are set by the cdc and an advisory
committee
likely health care workers high-risk
individuals are going to be first and
then it's going to start to move to
average risk
individuals but we have to make sure
especially when we're talking about a
vaccine that needs extreme cold storage
that we have the capacity
to keep that vaccine in places where
they don't necessarily have those
freezers so there are companies for
example
ups is building freezer farms so that
they can distribute from those freezer
farms the vaccine so
like i said this is going to be
something that requires a lot of
coordination
and i think it's going to be something
that that's going to be very difficult
even in the best of times
dr odaljo thank you